the chat yeah we're live all right hello hi everyone it's a pleasure to
have you with us today i my name is lisa nester i am a
senior strategist at the stellar development foundation and you are joining us for our
third roundtable discussion second topic that we've ever covered and we are very happy
to have you with us today so i guess to get started i'd love
to kind of frame again the purpose of these roundtable discussions hopefully we're going
to have a lot of audience members and viewers joining in and we'd love
to invite you into the discussion as well and then i'll jump into what
the topic for today is so in general at the stellar development foundation you
know we want to make sure that we're facilitating broad inclusive ecosystem driven discussion
around the types of tools that the stuller ecosystem needs to continue to grow
on and have successful use cases and businesses utilizing stuller and so in that
regard we've started these enterprise roundtable discussions to invite key enterprises within the stellar
ecosystem to sit down at a table with various members of the seller development
foundation to discuss topics that are really timely and important for the growth of
the ecosystem right now and as i've mentioned we also live stream these events
and have a q a box for any viewers so that we really can
do our best to include all of the voices in the ecosystem so if
you're watching us and you have comments or questions as we go through this
discussion please drop them in the chat box and we'll do our best to
respond and include those perspectives so for the discussion today we're going to be
talking about custodial versus non-custodial applications in the stellar ecosystem and so why is
this an important topic well the truth is that if you're building a product
on stuller or any blockchain network really one of the first things you have
to figure out is how to manage your user secret keys there are two
fundamentally different approaches that are seemingly practically and philosophically at odds custodial solution keeps
keep keys on behalf of users and non-custodial solutions put keys into users hands
and i think most of us would agree that during the early days of
stuller and also within the broader crypto landscape non-custodial wallet designs were kind of
by and far the default in my opinion this is because the novelty of
kind of being your own bank and having direct access to digital assets drove
forward applications and wallets that were primarily not custodial nature however as the stellar
ecosystem has grown over the last few years we have seen more custodial design
approaches by enterprise and our ecosystem so that's why we're opening up this discussion
today because we've seen a lot of growth in applications on stuller that are
getting more and more users we think it's a great time to check in
on how wallets are currently set up experiences people are having and how they're
thinking about moving forward and then also we have two at least two kind
of specific technical developments within the stellar ecosystem that are worth checking in on
as they're related to the specific topic at hand so one is cap 27
so cap 27 is allows first class multi multiplex accounts this was included in
protocol 13 and it basically allows services to map a single seller account to
multiple users and it could make custodial solutions a lot easier to build on
the other hand we also have sep 30 which is a recovery signer and
this defines an api that enables a user to regain access to a stellar
account after losing a private key without providing a third party control of the
account we're actually really lucky to have the key architect for step 30 lee
from the sdf joining us today and this solution in particular is something that
could make non-custodial solutions a bit easier so kind of checking in on where
things are at and also thinking about these two new technical developments this is
going to be the focus of our discussion today on custodial versus non-custodial solutions
so with that i would love to get started and i would love to
start by having our fantastic guests join us i will call you out just
because we're on screen and not in person so if i can invite marco
to stardust hello thanks for having us here my name is marco i am
one of the co-founders at saldo mx and anchor service for the mexican peso
wonderful thanks marco all right how about meinhard next yes so yeah my name
is mayanhard and i'm the ceo and founder of satoshi pay and recently we
launched d transfer which is a b2b cross-border money transfer service and that's kind
of the main focus of what we're doing right now awesome and actually for
god i said that i was going to ask a special surprise question so
we'll come back to you marco and this goes straight to you mine hard
any new quarantine hobbies that you've picked up over the last nine months we'll
say 20 20 new hobbies not strictly your hobby but i meditate every day
so that's going to be something i picked up okay this time yeah awesome
marco well this is exactly i mean not a hobby either but i've been
like learning a lot of cooking months so yeah and i enjoy it so
happy hopefully other people are enjoying it too that's awesome that's great cool and
then i will turn it over to you christian yes thanks for having me
i'm christian the cto and co-founder of d-stock so we do tokenized securities such
as apple and tesla and make them tradeable on the decks and yeah we're
live since i think not two or three months and have looked deep into
custodial solutions quite late great and any quarantine hobbies that you picked up not
really hobbies actually so actually the thing is in germany there was a lockdown
of schools as well so i was like after doing a lot of cryptographic
math in the last year i was doing a lot of primary school mars
this year when i was had to teach my daughter so that has become
my hobby that's fair enough that's good all right and so next i'll hand
it over to justin from the sdf hi i'm justin head of ecosystem at
the stellar development foundation excited to be here obviously well my team we care
a lot about what the ecosystem is doing and whenever there are improvements or
changes part of what we try to find out is whether they work for
the ecosystem and also how to get them out there so that everybody's using
them in a way that makes things interoperable so very interested to hear people's
feedback my quarantine hobby so far is asbestos remediation that's an important hobby i
hope everyone everyone checks it out any homeowner should make sure to develop that
hobby i live in an old house and it turns out there was a
lot of asbestos and okay that just becomes a consuming thing it can yeah
absolutely okay and then last but not least lee yeah hi i'm i'm liam
khalik i'm a software engineer at the stellar development foundation and i contribute to
sets like sub 30 septem and yeah i'm just really interested in custodial and
non-custodial solutions and how we make them interoperable well sounds like you're in the
right place lee but you can you don't get away without letting us know
if you have any quarantine hobbies as well similar similar similar to christian definitely
became a teacher as well okay those are skills that will pay off though
i'm sure so that's great i myself picked up skateboarding and this thing called
a rip stick a little bit that's kind of like a cool that was
you know a good way to when maybe there's no commute it was a
nice way to spend the afternoons after work so okay great well i would
love to dive in i guess straight into the meat of it which is
i'd love to hear what each of you are doing for your current custodial
strategy with estoc and saldo and satoshi bay and you know maybe a little
bit about why you chose that approach and how you're thinking about things now
moving forward so minehart perhaps we'll start with you sure so at satoshi bay
we essentially have three major services one is the micro payment service that we're
known for micropayment for digital content then there's obviously the solar wallet open source
stellar wallet and then recently there's d transfer and all of all of them
use a wallet solution that's self-custodial and i'm saying self-control here because internally we
use that word instead of non-custodial because we think non-custodial is a bit misleading
because there is a custodian which is yourself and so we chose to be
self-custodial essentially just to have everything be software and all the trust is in
software and not in any external party not even us this helps us to
move further or to release products to the market much quicker and also has
removed a huge overhead in potential regulation or regulatory regulatory requirements that we have
to fulfill so we can just push out the software and sort of have
people manage their own private keys and therefore being really just a software provider
in that sense and that being said so for d transfer we recently also
released a self custodial resolution on monday actually to production and here we really
give users the full control over the funds and also the reason again is
a regulatory one however in the future we plan to give users a choice
maybe that they can either have a custodial solution by us or by some
other external the custodial party that we partner with or even combine both approaches
that's super interesting i mean is that something that would be a relatively easy
opt-in decision to kind of automate from a back-end perspective or would these need
to be two totally separate kind of infrastructure solutions so yeah so the combination
would be very separate or not very but a pretty separate legal let's say
connections that we have with our users and also technically it would be quite
different yeah so that's also where the different caps and steps come into play
each on their side so it's going to be quite some development work and
also some some let's say legal ground work that we have to lay first
what is motivating you to consider adding this second solution where you provide custody
mainly user experience because a lot of the customers we have are not familiar
with this sort of power that self has so also the power to lose
your money essentially and that is something we want to maybe give users the
choice if they you know want to be in full control or if they
trust us with a certain amount of of their money or even all of
their money like a more like a bank-like service it's also right now we
didn't find a custody partner yet and also we're not regulated in that way
so it's we can't actually legally launch a self or sorry a custodial solution
at this point but we can launch the self custodial and that's why we
move forward with that with that we can now handle bigger transactions as well
as much as there's digits and there's let's say a stellar code we can
we can add like even very large amounts if we want that's great i
really want to dive into some of those points more specifically around you know
the usability side of things and i'm also kind of curious to hear for
the users that you think would want a non-custodial solution kind of what is
a driver or motivator there as well but maybe let's go ahead and jump
to marco to get a little bit more of our landscape about where we're
all currently or where you're currently sitting yeah thanks well philosophically i'm personally very
aligned with the self-custody movement that you know cryptocurrency has started and i don't
see for example in in single asset blockchain such as bitcoin the really the
need of of thinking through like custodial solutions but however i i've i've seen
stellar since the very beginning seeing and realizing the market opportunity of representing real-world
assets on on on this public network and allow exchanges and and transfers and
that requires a lot of companies like ours to that are regulated entities capable
of of holding value for on the behalf of their users to participate and
the needs actually that these companies have is is they're very different because like
they want to leverage the this ability to hold people's funds and and be
able to to like improve usability as much as possible and remove any any
friction that can be created by by the self-custody approach which we all know
very well and i think what what we've seen is under development especially you
know from from from the ecosystem of standards that can help expand those custodial
solutions and and and i think that's something that we should think through more
and focus because the same way that in cryptocurrency has has been like expanding
thanks in big part to exchanges which are custodial solutions i think that it
at the end of the day it will be extremely beneficial for all if
more custodial solutions are able to to adopt the the kind of the stellar
protocol in in in a way that makes sense for them and in that
way increase the use of of the whole network and and benefit including like
those players that are that are using self-custody solutions yeah i mean i think
that this is you know it's i think there's kind of a philosophical point
of tension here where you know i think many of the people within the
stellar community really like the financial sovereignty that blockchain can provide but there's also
typically a deep desire to create impact to use a platform like stellar to
provide more access to financial products and services for everyone right and so how
do we do that in really simple ways or how do we do that
in ways that work across user types outside of just people who really understand
cryptocurrency so but marco can you help clarify how does saldo actually work how
are you set up right now yeah so we we as an anchor support
like both like approaches so if someone wants to you know utilize our services
through a non-custodial solution like lobster they can go ahead and do it but
we're also maintaining a service that it's called smx that it's our custodial solution
that we believe it's really important for for for the business development of of
our company so that basically is a very easy way to to use a
wallet that allows especially mexicans who are in in the us working hard and
sending money over to hold a little bit of mexican pesos in in in
a digital way and and that replaces the need to go and cross the
border and open a bank account which is almost impossible for for the majority
of them so like we are really focusing on this community which is not
tech savvy he's not a part of the crypto community at all and and
and we've been like super motivated from from what we've seen and and and
and this is a community that actually could not care less about like the
self sovereign aspect of crypto but they just want like the task to be
done and so they we've been like developing these with these people in mind
and and that's for our company a big focus right now and and and
and we also want to make it compatible with with any other stellar-based solution
but in our in in in our approach this is a fully custodial way
of doing the of using our anchor gotcha and it sounds like you already
have some thoughts on where there could be more support within the stellar ecosystem
for being able to kind of launch these types of products yeah i i
think that you know they're already there a lot of interesting discussions like the
like the moxed like multiplexed accounts that you mentioned but probably we yeah we
and i'm sure we will talk more about this later on but i think
that it's it's in general very interesting just to kind of like see what
the users are doing and and and and just like see that basically the
entire world it's it's it's gonna take a long time for for for the
majority of people to adopt like the self-custody tools out there and i think
that we should like be kind of like aware that there's a path towards
that kind of like decentralization and in the meantime it's really important to serve
the people that they want to be served in a in a specific way
and and for us like we are at a stage in which is really
important to to provide a custodial and easy to use solutions like like this
great yeah and i think we definitely will dive into some of these various
things like multiplexed accounts more so great thank you so much marco and christian
i know you guys have had an interesting journey with these talks so we'd
love to hear about what you guys are using how you set things up
and how you're thinking about the future yeah i already have a lot of
points i want to touch on so yeah maybe i can start with there
are actually two different ways how you or multiple ways actually how you can
use these stock technologies so first of all there's an api layer which basically
everyone can use it uses stellar standards and people can build products on top
of it and for that one we actually don't have any opinion on what
the user how the user protects his key his or her keys so we
just basically verify the user and where he's coming from if it's not like
a terrorist something like that and then they can use their account to trade
our assets but we as well that's our actually main product do we have
a mobile app and because countries we serve emerging markets there's a mobile first
approach and this app is actually not targeting crypto users so if you want
to use if you're a stellar heavy user and you want to use these
stock assets you can use for example lobster wallet or something like that but
for already non-crypto users who are new to investing and haven't had touch points
at all with crypto in the past it's actually quite quite of a hard
concept to grasp to create a private key so like currently in our onboarding
process which is self custodial i'm going to start to use this word as
well it's an xd minor the people actually in the onboarding process have to
create a private key and we see actually some some kind of a drop-off
rate right on that so it's like people have a hard time doing that
so i understand that they're a bit scared maybe they don't understand it and
things like that so that that's a problem actually to us and i think
to to everyone who wants to build end user product that's not just targeting
early adopted adopters and the tricky part on this one is like in the
very heart of d stock is that d stock itself does not hold customer
customers funds so that's that's the basic idea how how we can actually pull
off the entire business and that's true for for most of of crypto companies
i guess that they don't hold customers funds and are therefore eligible to cut
off a lot of middlemen that are normally required in financial transactions and yeah
so basically if we want to want to go away from that and we're
actually planning to do that so we need to we want to find a
solution that makes it easier for undo this we have to go to some
way that's not only self-custodial and i'm not saying well let me phrase it
differently the first thing that we need to define or that we have to
talk about is what actually does custodian what what does the custodial solution mean
in this case and this definition isn't actually as clear as i would as
one would guess so we're always talking about okay they're self solving their self-custodial
solutions and custodial solutions but the definition of custodial is quite a bit more
complex i've read it to the bit for example the barfin which is a
german equivalent roughly the german equivalent to the icc in america defines custody as
someone who's holding a funds off on behalf of other people is able to
transfer them make payments with that and all this kind of stuff and all
holds a private key that's eligible to do that and for example in step
30 that's where you say okay we're splitting off weights between third parties that
need to jointly recover a key for user that's not really that definition so
it's not really clear that's actually a custodial solution that would require regulations so
like by the very definition of financial regulators it may not be but it's
actually not that clear because it's just basically new land so nobody has actually
challenged that maybe the regulators weren't even aware that their weighted keys things like
that says the entire entire field is it's not as easy as it gets
so for us it's like very crucial to find a solution where we say
okay people will be able to recover the key but i wouldn't call that
a custodian custodial solution because the people does do not hold the funds of
the user in custody they're not able to to transfer them doing stuff with
that and more importantly they are not able to yeah then they don't have
to do insurance and things like that for it so yeah that's that's the
basic thing i'll sing around it so customian solutions are non-custodials who should be
it's not the only thing in the real midst as well just mainly for
us about key recovery that we want to try to solve that's great i
mean i guess i'm curious do you mine heart or marco have kind of
like a similar opinion or reaction extremely relevant and interesting because for example i
think that for you know for a lot of regulators the fact that a
user of of a regulated entity actually goes and does something and and loses
the private key is not sufficient like for the regulator to to just be
fined the the legal obligation you know that that the company has still is
is is a valid payment obligation that the company needs to honor so i
think it's it's not sufficient just to you know like it's it's it's like
the key management will not remove or will not make go away that legal
kind of like obligation that some custodial companies have and and that it's it's
it's something that it's very like valid across like all the kind of like
real world assets including currencies and i think you know like at that point
like you realize that somehow for example if if a user of of our
anchor loses like the private key and you still see the funds you at
least need to show that you have a process to be able to to
in a way cancel those funds or or or do something with with that
account and then like credit back those tokens to the new or or like
re-key kind of like you know like doing those things it's it helps companies
like ours to comply with with local regulations that are not aware of like
what what private keys can do and i think it's like super interesting and
makes companies like ours realize that it's it's a very complex topic that that
is an interesting point you make oh you go first planet okay then that's
interesting okay sorry for that that's an interesting point to raise i mean when
you when you when you're anchoring an asset you always have the option to
freeze it and okay it's still still on chain and it's a bit harder
to keep track of it but it's still in an automated way you can
can prove that this assets are frozen when you when you for example kind
of take away trust lines and then you can issue the token the assets
new and that's that's it's somewhat of a cumbersome way it may be easier
in the future because there are some proposed changes to stellar to to reclaim
assets but this is some way for us for example to to recover recover
funds at the moment even if the people lose their their key in their
self-custodial solution the problem is actually not from that so we can always do
that the problem is merely if the user just for example deposits a million
in excel and then loses this key or her key or the same for
for stablecoin so may not be able up to this process so but the
the interesting idea of just reading the assets and reissuing them to new accounts
is always an option as well that's so you don't have to so that
you just give up the old account when you lose the key just just
on that briefly obviously you need to flag the asset as being revocable and
yeah there's acid types where you work there's configurations where you don't have that
so if you forgot to do that or if you didn't plan for that
then obviously that's not possible either so what we've done in our micro payments
product actually we used a little bit of a trick there so we are
co-signing all the transactions that are being done from for the micropens wallets and
we also have a time locked transaction that we issue with each payment meaning
that after a certain period of time the funds will return back to us
if no other transactions have been made meaning that if the user loses a
key and they flag us they tell us that they did so we will
simply not co-sign any transactions from that key anymore and then after half a
year i think it's currently the time that we have programmed we can then
recover these funds that means we can issue even lumens to the users from
we kind of give out a bit of our liquidity beforehand but in that
way we can also sort of have a account recovery for accounts that actually
are lost but the funds will come back to us later after half a
year sort of a sort of a workaround for that issue but isn't co-signing
the definition of it not being as purely self-custodial depends on the type of
weight a key has so if you have you know like a minority weight
and then so i don't know how the regulator regulator sees different types of
water signatures because that's also depending on the chain obviously i well it's a
hybrid i would say yeah and i think you know just to kind of
respond here so one i wanted to flag christian had mentioned a cap on
stuller which i wanted to name just if anybody's watching yeah cap 35 which
is the asset clawback cap which is a new proposal so if anyone's interested
in exploring that further but you know this is really interesting because it still
feels like we're dancing around these areas of kind of how can you stay
lean and you know i would say kind of do things that allow you
as an organization to kind of have a leaner regulatory framework as authentic along
with things that are more tied to kind of like usability and how do
we make experiences for consumers to that can keep their information safe but still
provide kind of like non-confusing not overburdened some experiences on the product i mean
do you guys see any other major areas that are kind of i'll say
kind of like dancing around the surface here because i know we're kind of
talking back and forth about various designs but it feels like there's kind of
like larger larger themes or larger questions so maybe i i can start because
i i i mean we we we've been like also thinking about this the
problem is that if honestly it is true that it removes liability the fact
that you can actually delegate the key management to your users and that like
fundamentally will remove like regular regulatory like load the problem is that if you
see what happens in in fintech is that okay regulation is more expensive than
software sure but is it at the top of the list i don't think
so it's like you have software which is cheap and then you have regulation
which is way more expensive and then you have distribution so if you see
like what's the big expenses that the companies have it's most like distribution a
customer acquisition cost is what sometimes kills like the unit economics so it's not
regulation at all even if it's like super expensive so i think that a
lot of companies realize that okay yeah there's some efficiencies to be made in
in that you know liability that goes away but it's not the entire story
so you still will need to go and find the users and that's like
extremely expensive and then sometimes it's even more expensive if you need to make
them learn what like a 12 like 12 word password means or what like
a mechanism to like that it's not intuitive is to recover like the secret
key for your funds so that those things will add costs to that very
like heavy heavy cost of of customer acquisition or will reduce that the universe
of people that you can target and i think that's something that from the
business perspective it's it's not very positive so so i have a question which
is basically if you had something i mean and this sort of relates specifically
to step 30 which i think is a very clever way to give users
access to their account without ever having them to touch a password or know
a secret key or use a backup recovery phase they can basically log into
a stellar account using just their phone number or their email address some proof
of identity right so with a with a solution like that you know well
i guess there's two questions one does a solution like that solve the user
experience and allow you to create a non-custodial sort of interface or solution that
doesn't feel that sort of obfuscates the crypto nature of an app from a
user like basically can using something like sub30 make it so that a user
experience for non-custodial wallet is just like a custodial wallet one and two if
it does does it solve the biggest problems or does it only solve some
of the problems and there are still a lot of problems left over that
would still make you choose to use a custodial solution i mean maybe i
can i can just quickly say that i think it's the final user who
will judge those things because at the end of the day for me it's
very intuitive to use a memo id just to identify a final user that
that actually hasn't been the case for the majority of users of exchanges so
in a way like something that feels very intuitive in from the kind of
the sign point of view and this is this is true across many different
steps that for me makes a lot of sense but once that they're implemented
like things become trickier and i think that's the only thing that i that
i could say probably christian can say much more yeah well i think well
first of all i like the basic idea of study and it's definitely a
valid one we we do have some problems with it by when we want
to to implement it that it's one thing that that's very common among when
we implement step ecosystem proposals for those who don't know our standards in the
stutter system that anchors or people building on it can implement and then everyone
can use it and it's interoperable between different clients and that is that is
a good thing if you're a client for example there is step six and
set 24 for deposits and withdrawals from anchors and it's super nice so basically
i am as a developer i can go ahead and integrate 10 of them
in a day and that's super nice for me as a client developer but
to be honest it's not something i care about as a developer what i
care about is optimization of the user flow so for example deposits is the
most crucial thing in our flow ever and if i can increase conversion there
by one percent or by five percent or by ten percent then i would
do that so it's not it's i'm not fundamentally not interested in getting this
thing done fast i want to get it done right and currently i can't
do a b testing i can't do client-side validations with steps and withdrawals for
example just just as an example for for seventy grade so this sep integration
as a whole focus on clients getting the job done and that's not what
we want to do and tab 30 is kind of the same thing it
has it it automates the entire flow for our clients that we can just
do it and then integrate a little integrate a lot with a lot of
other clients who integrate 30 but it's it's not coming from from the perspective
of the client so for example i'll give you an example quite lately quite
recently i've lost my two-factor authentication and i think was coinbase and it wasn't
an automated process i had to censor my passport there was a person talking
to me and that's that's fine it's something i would expect as a user
and it encouraged me that this those people do their business right whereas on
step 30 if the ease of the flow is like okay my email my
sms is something i wouldn't fundamentally like as a user to be connected with
me that i'm just pushing a tech away from losing my entire life saving
savings when someone captures my email and my wife quite recently changed her phone
number she doesn't even have access to a whole number anymore so it's like
it's it's kind of a weak thing for us and it focuses a lot
of it's being automated people don't have to hassle with it it's fully integrated
it's decentralized and that's fundamentally not anything our users care about the basic care
you just want to log into the app have an account and never care
about it and for us it would be totally fine if there would be
just a person having an hd wallet in the physical world and it costs
like thirty dollars or ten dollars or twenty dollars for key recovery because if
it's below it doesn't make sense anyways if it's above fine or we could
scale it but having an approach that's just focusing on the client side wouldn't
cut it for our users so we would we would have to have have
a process that's that's more tied to the user experience and the user doesn't
want to want to care about that at all i think that just for
my side i talked a lot so maybe i'll keep it shut now do
you do you think that there's like i think i think we've mentioned in
a few points like there's this there's this issue of keys being lost and
then what do people what do users go through to get their keys back
and then we're talking separately about the products we're developing and all the functionality
they provide do you think that there's room for custody as a product independent
of the products you're developing so maybe i can take this one definitely so
i don't know if this is starting to christian but definitely for us that
would be something we desperately want the ecosystem and it would have to be
a custodian that supports different stellar assets as well and there are wallets that
support lumens already and insurance that support lumix but to extend that to other
assets and maybe even traits to some extent that would be definitely something we
would want to integrate and that's actually what we're actively looking for i would
want to make again the separation between custody and key recovery so we don't
want to have custody we don't want one want want so traditional custody solutions
work like they don't expose a private key to anyone but even the users
belonging to that and you send transactions to some kind of signing service to
give it back so we we don't want that we won't always want to
have self custody and the user be in charge of the things with his
with possession of his or her own key what we want on top is
key recovery solutions pretty much like sub 30 would offer it conceptually with multiple
recovery processes as as weights where not each weight does not have the option
to to trade but i understand where he was coming from it was it
was developed with a different thing in mind it was what was basically developed
for the use case of not only key recovery it was as well developed
for sharing keys and all kind of use cases that are required alongside when
you're not the only one having access to that key and for that step
study makes a totally perfect job i think it's just like for our purposes
but we don't want one all of those features we just basically want at
any any and in a very seldom selling case someone loses his or her
key can recover it and for that i think it would be fine if
there would be just like two or three maybe notaries or trust trust companies
banks whatever who would provide the service and maybe maybe just a call center
or something like that where people could provide their id's and initiate a recovery
process so for the users of ours that would it doesn't have to be
this decentralized solution because most of the users are not crypto maximalists who said
everything needs to be decentralized and all these kind of things one thing if
i could make make a proposal that's a bit more technical involved would be
that it's fundamental to stellar to have counterparty risk right so you have to
establish trust lines to assets or anchors where you say okay i trust those
people so they say maybe for this you say hello these people are sitting
in europe they are they are test by the regulators there that's a bank
bank in europe that hold the assets in custody so that's great i trust
those guys i encourage you to do so i established a trust line to
to these stock assets and maybe that would be true for custodians as well
where you can say hey i'm establishing some kind of custodian custodial trust lines
where i say hey this guy can or girl or entity can hold a
specific weight of my assets so that you have it somehow baked into the
protocol level but that's just for the far future for the very near future
it would be just basically fine to have two or three who are not
who are who establish trust by being used by many of the enterprises building
up on stellar marco and my heart i'm interested if that idea appeals to
the two of you also which idea that basically the idea of there being
sort of trusted custodian professional custodians out there that that you could i think
in general it's it it it fulfills a need i i've seen always stellar
as a very diverse ecosystem and i think that the problem of like discussing
topics of like one solution versus the other it's like it's not giving the
full picture of what's happening so stellar actually for example i the way i
see it is that at least in the ecosystem we touch there are multiple
different roles and and and they will like some of them like will require
something like that and some of them won't so for example like we're thinking
imagine a migrant worker that has the need to send over 200 that's not
the same need of the market maker that facilitates like the exchange rates that
those other people benefit from that actually move millions of dollars so so so
that that makes completely different needs and they're both using stellar so i think
in in in in one case like shared keys are badly needed and in
other ways what what some other projects are are doing which is like completely
abstract in a way and and and you know i why why would a
company like ours would have the liability of the people's funds that's because like
there aren't a lot of funds maybe you can you can actually because you're
solving probably you have like you know capital requirements that exceed those people's funds
so like those things will at the end of the day mitigate the risks
and will make you capable of fronting such risks and i think that's that's
what that's what i see so in in my mind there's a lot of
like sophisticated players in the storage system already in a way that understand like
how the mechanics work but they aren't yet as many users as i would
like to see i love to see every mexican who's working in a kitchen
in new york using a system that touches stellar and and and when you
do that it's in my mind a product that completely looks like something that
this community would expect and that's completely something far from from from something like
except 30 or something like that because they don't want to deal with that
it just one like deal with the same thing that they've been doing with
other companies when things fail and and and that's like the market needed that
we've seen yeah absolutely and i mean just one point that you made there
that i do think is really important is that you know even when we're
thinking about the requirements for just an application oftentimes there's a whole kind of
like broader stack of ecosystem that's required to kind of make that end product
exist and everybody who's in that value chain has kind of differing needs based
on what they're doing so so yeah i think that's fair you know i'd
say well we're in our last 15 minutes here and so you know i
think we're already kind of doing this but i i would love to drive
the discussion towards kind of identifying gaps or needs or we could also put
these as opportunities within the ecosystem and so maybe i'll just phrase this in
a slightly constraining manner to to kick things off like if you marco meinhard
and christian could wave a magic wand and have like one new thing exist
in the stellar ecosystem to support your vision of key management what would that
look like like what's the the number one thing that you think would be
super valuable for you whoever wants whoever has a response to that i can
start by by the the already multiplexed accounts that that we've touched before it's
in general i think that that's something that in my mind is something that
that was missing and i think i would love to see completely adopted and
the reason is because the way that i feel as a user like the
way that memo ids are used it's kind of like not intuitive and and
it's it's it feels like a hack you know like you know every everyone's
familiar with with a payment app where you can also like include a message
that travels with with with a payment and so but in this specific case
we're like hacking that field that memo field to actually embed information and that
will make the payment to route differently so that became like the the default
way of adopting stellar like for exchanges and i think that you know the
entire ecosystem accepted that was the way to do it but i think if
there's a better way to do it which in my in my mind it
is multiplexed accounts we should like the sooner the better adopt something like that
because you can actually free that field which is important for other use cases
as an example the first implementation we did for bill pay actually encoded information
about the bill that like the reference of the invoice that that was intended
to be paid and that was encrypted and sent over the memo so it's
like to me those are things that other players may may find like useful
and interesting and will design that way and if we use that field as
just an additional feel that together with the with the address we'll actually run
the payment to to a different like destination i think that that's completely in
my mind something that shouldn't work that way and and and and you know
some evidence is like people make a lot of mistakes when they're like put
assets in and out of exchanges and i think it feels like it's it
would be focusing on on people and companies using custodial wallets but i think
it's the opposite i think if it's widely adopted it's something that it would
be there available for everybody and they will like just add a more intuitive
way to just send payments to an address with an amount and that will
like like satisfy the need of like the routing and and and all the
information that needs to travel with each payment so in my mind that's something
that needs to be adopted obviously discussed before and and and for me that
that wouldn't be like that so you're you're putting your flag down on the
cap 27 planet in the stellar ecosystem and i don't know where i'm going
with this but you're you're squarely on the cap 27 multiplexed account team yeah
i think i i think so okay great wonderful meinhard looks like you maybe
have a thing next great yeah so also cap 27 is really interesting for
us and that's something unfortunately i can't answer maybe a leak and clarify does
it also sort of protects the privacy of the recipients or is it still
easy to to like conclude the address that's behind it because that is something
also we would wish to have that we have not the complete balance of
all of our clients immediately visible to maybe a sender and so in a
way not anonymous but partially anonymous transactions at least for the recipient that would
be quite interesting for us and then also something that christian earlier said like
a sort of a footed approach or a feathered federated approach for key recovery
or even for a coastal resolution that would be definitely quite interesting and then
you said i should pick one thing but maybe also you can say a
third thing it would be a sort of regulated entities that are offering this
custody as a service and not just key recovery so that's definitely something we
would that would solve a lot of problems for us right now because fundamentally
we're not really also because of our consumer's perspective or our user's perspective maximalists
and and like you have to own your key ultimately we want to offer
a a transfer service that passes on all the advantages of blockchain or stellar
in this case mainly speed and transaction cost and also the transparency and it
doesn't have to be fully self-custodial in our sense like we want to give
the user the choice and the user doesn't really care much about that they
should have a online banking like experience and that we need to know what's
what's behind it and not also having the need to learn new vocabulary and
new approaches so that's like how we want to place our service that makes
sense yeah i i i concur that you know it seems like having along
with there being some kind of technical aspects to creating more capabilities around key
management there's also potentially ecosystem partners that we could bring in that would really
support this as well so and then lee did you do you know on
cap 27 if it adds any anonymity or i'm not sure if that's something
you're too up to date on so yeah so i can answer that it
not not specifically so there's not like a feature cap 27 that that would
make it any more anonymous than using a memo id for a transaction however
you know the service that's using the services using cap 27 you know could
rotate ids for users so they could change the id that a user is
using over time or or you use some other strategies like that that obviously
has some disadvantages if if somebody is treating a cap 27 like a market
address as a you know an actual address for that user if it's changing
that could be problematic but i feel like this is this is similar to
virtual credit card numbers where you have like a credit card and then you
have like model ones you use for different merchants maybe or different people things
like that okay great thank you lee and then christian yeah well there's a
short time and there's long term so basically we're fundamentally focusing on non-crypto users
and for non-crypto users convenience is important so there's a reason why why why
things like what's app are more popular than things like ebay's because they are
just more convenient and user slower in terms of the more convenient solution all
those but but i think that fundamentally the the key recovery is not should
be easy on the recovery process the recovery process can be hard if i
lose my wallets like my physical wallets my credit cards in it i'm up
for that that it will be a complicated process to get that all sorted
so that that's fine but setting up my wallet and setting up my my
key that you that should be the easy part and for us like the
easiest solution would be just hey on the concretion when you create your account
on d stock we would just add two or three trusted and reputable public
keys and those people do have some kind of recovery process if i wouldn't
be totally filled with work at d stock i would right now fund a
company started start a startup doing exactly that because there's a need for that
and like in the long term i could see that i'm better than the
protocol that's the one thing i said was having trust lines to these custodials
pretty much like you have trust lines to to add to assets or anchors
would be a nice way maybe even you you could one could think about
that when you have an account and it holds assets from multiple different anchors
that you can say that those anchors could jointly recover and cover your key
by depending on the weights and how many assets you have there as well
as cloud acid clawback with cap 35 could put a great job into that
but that's like it would be awesome to have it in the protocol embedded
but like for our needs it wouldn't even be required for short-term solution would
be just like victory hey let's get two or three trustable notary solicitors something
like that out there that we all trust and where we say hey let's
give each other it doesn't cost me a lot of money so that it
could be like small small no trees that are just regulated in some country
and you just say put them up put a process behind that that you
can recover and then i think it would be fine question just to as
a quick clarification i'm not sure i can exactly actually conceptualize what this would
look like if it was embedded in the protocol and i know it's like
very early stages high level but i mean could you maybe illustrate that a
little bit more like what what you think that would look like basically that
if you have so the basic idea currently is that you have at public
keys as a signer and what you could do is when you say hey
we we create trust licenses and take that for custodian but these custodians could
jointly recover your key even though they don't have weights in your public key
could be so basically they they would have these anchors would have a public
private keeper somewhere on the chain and this public private keeper would have the
right to recover addresses they would have been added as a signer but you
don't have to explicitly had them as a signer so basically you create a
trust line to three custodians and then these three custodians could jointly recover your
funds but you don't have to add them as a signer so you don't
have this kind of multi-signature thing added to your account gotcha gotcha okay that's
really useful great well this has been a super interesting and useful discussion and
i have to say and i'm sure justin and lee feel the same you
know there's been a lot to take in and digest i really appreciate you
guys sharing your perspective and opinion on this and i have a feeling we're
we're kind of just kicking this discussion off so we did have one or
two questions from the audience which i will get up in front of me
in just a second oh not that one there we go so i'll just
throw this out to everyone i guess can non-custodial wallet apps connect to a
bank and have a user receive funds in their native currency so that's kind
of like a non-custodial to custodial payout flow i believe the answer to this
is yes this is actually a type of payment flow that we facilitate on
stellar yeah i don't know i think this is the intention of of all
those all the steps that have been adopted so it's like normally an anchor
that complies with with the existing seps what they would do is basically allow
non-custodial solution to be able to get from an anchor services like ours like
for example a bank informations that they can like go from their own bank
account to to like the bank account that the anchor has and then that
would in exchange you know give the user some some some equivalent of of
tokens so that that flow it's it's it's precisely how today all of all
of the active anchors are are doing yeah you can use lobster or vibrant
to deposit a number of different anchors because they they already interoperate perfect great
thanks guys and then maybe justin this one's for you step 30 and cap
27 both look cool do any of the dev libraries or wallets support these
currently yeah that's an interesting question and part of why i think it was
good to start to have this discussion cap 27 which marco advocated for earlier
but has come up a couple of times is called multiplexed accounts it adds
a new kind of stellar address at the protocol level basically allows a single
stellar account to map to multiple users it was added to protocol 13. however
there's it's kind of like we put in the wiring but we didn't put
any plugs or switches right like there's no manifestation of this and horizon are
in the sdks and there's no clear way no clear like methods or standards
for actually using these mixed accounts so they're there they're just hidden away and
so with those cap 27 specifically in order to really be able to use
it we'd first have to build out the sort of platform layers on top
of the protocol and then we'd have to start working with people to figure
out how they would actually use those so cap 27 is possible but not
really implemented in in any existing applications step 30 on the other hand which
is is not at the protocol level right it basically specifies how you can
split key recovery across multiple different servers run by different by different operators right
so instead of having a single key or instead of trying it it relies
on third parties running these things called recovery servers right now vibrant which is
a a wallet that sort of is facilitates usd savings at the moment mostly
that relies that that uses two recovery servers to implement sub 30 but if
other people in the ecosystem wanted to start implementing sub 30 in their wallets
this specific key recovery method we would need to as an ecosystem get people
to run these things recovery servers right recovery servers which are sort of the
servers that you delegate to allow a user to access their account if they
lose their key so short answer step 30 is implemented in one wallet and
could be in more if we set up recovery servers that people could use
and by we i mean the ecosystem as a whole having to add one
point so this idea that i mentioned about having trust lines for focus for
not custodians but for key recovery people the the major change that it would
add sorry my microphone brother the major change that it would add to the
current solution is that the current solution if you add it as a signer
like in step 30 then you are always getting the other rights as well
so you can always like jointly transfer funds and stuff like that having these
kind of recovery service at the protocol level then it would really be just
okay i'm adding those people and they can they can give me a process
to recover my keys but they can never do payments transactions even if they
are colluding or jointly hacked those kind of stuff and that would put a
lot of clearance on the legal side and it would make this the entire
setup a lot easier you don't have to store keys online and things like
that so just clarify that yeah i i i i know that we don't
have like a lot of time left but i think it's it's it's interesting
to keep the conversation going especially because i think the multiplexed accounts can offer
actually widely adopted some level of of obfuscation to the payments if like people
start using it because as as lee said like people can use them as
as you know like like as dynamic debit card numbers and and it's interesting
if the entire ecosystem adopts it then like people would be sending money over
with different m accounts and that will like obvious scale a lot of the
the information which is really interesting yeah well it sounds like on both fronts
both on kind of step 30s key recovery design and muxed accounts on the
cop27 side we have a lot of thinking to do i think you know
as we kind of said in the beginning this is the beginning of these
conversations or maybe the middle i guess they've been going on for a while
so we'll definitely be continuing them so with that i would say you know
i think it's time to to wrap up the discussion today but i think
it's likely we may want to all meet back here in a few months
certainly after meridian and continue this conversation hopefully making some progress in the time
between so you know again christian mind hard marco we can't thank you enough
for your time today and for sharing your perspective and i hope everyone has
a wonderful halloween weekend and we'll talk again soon thanks everybody thanks everybody